premier ses libertés individuelles pour
assurer sa santé voilà tout l'objet du
débat un débat qui devrait faire en si
fier ces prochains jours au sein de
l'assemblée nationale
puisqu'un vote va avoir lieu une avancée
considérable quand on se souvient des
propos de christophe castaner fin mars
concernant le trafic cela n'est pas la
culture française
je fais confiance aux français pour que
nous n'ayons pas à mettre en place ces
systèmes qui au fond atteignent la
liberté individuelle de chacun pour être
efficace donc ce n'est pas un sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons
dix jours après cette déclaration
finalement le ministre de l'intérieur
laisse entendre que cet outil pourrait
faire partie des solutions retenues par
le gouvernement s'il est soutenu par
l'ensemble de la population une réponse
certainement à ce sondage de
l'université britannique d'oxford
il montre que huit français sur dix
seraient favorables à l'utilisation
d'une application enregistrant leurs
interactions sociales et les avertissant
s'ils ont été en contact avec une
personne malade ducobu 19 ou prévenant
ceux qui l'ont côtoyé s ils sont
infectés nous y voilà presque un mois
plus tard l'application stop qu'ovide
est prévu pour accompagner le
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai mais
plusieurs problèmes vont se poser tout
d'abord là ça soulève des questions sur
les libertés individuelles
le droit à l'anonymat le secret médical
le libre consentement la gestion des
données collectées sur l'efficacité du
tracking aussi il ya débat directement
liée au nombre d'utilisateurs
ce sera sur la base du volontariat on ne
soutiendra jamais des mesures
coercitives
concrètement dans cette phase de
déconfinement si vous l'acceptez pas ce
que vous pensez que c'est un rôle
citoyen vous vous inscrivez sur une
plateforme qui fonctionne par bluetooth
le bluetooth et la plus grande
contrainte technique à laquelle le
gouvernement fait face et c'est ce qui
pourrait faire tomber à l'eau ce projet
à d'applications la raison apple
interdit depuis plusieurs années sur ces
appareils
l'activation du bluetooth par défaut
l'exemple de singapour est privilégiée
par le gouvernement
le pays a adopté cette technique mais
pas forcément ses habitants puisque
seulement 15 % de la population à
télécharger l'application
il est clair dans les conditions
actuelles que l'application stop covit
nécessiterait d'être ouverte et active
en permanence apple devra donc faire des
concessions qui est loin d'être gay s'il
peut accepter
pas de modifier ses critères techniques
l'application que nous construisons avec
nos partenaires européens notamment
allemands suisses et bientôt italien
anglais et monégasques ne sera jamais
prête pour le 11 mai et sans l'aide
d'apple tout autre solution qui ne
passerait pas par la modification des
conditions de fonctionnement de leur
appareil serait une espèce de bricolage
pour éviter ce bricolage des
négociations sont en cours entre le
gouvernement et le géant américain
de son côté apple tente d'avancer sur
une solution de sortie en étroite
collaboration avec google alliance
inédite qui pourrait résoudre ce
problème
quoi qu'il en soit ce problème technique
met en exergue la question de fond qui
se joue derrière le tracking le respect
de la vie privée et des libertés
individuelles